batman v superman uh let's see
superman can lift a truck fly and shoot
laser beams out of his eyes
all at the same time batman has
ice skates case closed not by a long
shot
get ready to put your money on batman
hello internet welcome to film theory
where today we're looking at the most
absurd matchup of 2016.
no i'm not talking about the election
we're talking about batman vs superman
now i'm sure i wasn't the only one to
see the title batman v
superman and just start laughing i mean
seriously
how can anyone let alone a regular human
beat an
all-powerful alien with a seemingly
limitless set of abilities
even screwattack's death battle
concluded that anime's number one hero
goku an unstoppable fighting machine
able to fuse with other fighters
channel the energy of the entire
universe and literally become a god
would lose in a fight against the
all-american hero
and they came to that same result not
once but twice
even with goku having the most powerful
item in existence at his side
the comment section wanting him to win
nothing beats that
so what chance does batman batman have
in a battle like that
forget batman v superman a more accurate
title would be
superman wins the end there i just saved
you 20 bucks on movie tickets
you're welcome but hold on before you go
out and spend that money to see deadpool
a sixth time
sure vegas may put the odds at a
thousand to one in favor of superman but
what if i told you that
despite the odds batman with the help of
some science could very
easily win this fight that's right i'm
putting all my money on the old
emotionally unstable guy
in a leather costume and ridiculous
voice if we believe there's even a one
percent chance that he is our enemy we
have to take it as an
absolute certainty and no we're not
talking about kryptonite everyone knows
that
that magical rock is superman's only
weakness exposed to kryptonite superman
crumbles faster than a moviegoer
watching
jiggly but we're making this a fair and
realistic fight no kryptonite involved
like last episode when we killed off
deadpool i'm gonna figure out a tangible
scientifically accurate way that bruce
wayne as a normal human could defeat an
unstoppable
alien comic book figure so where do we
start
well in the words of sun tzu know the
enemy which means we need to know what
makes superman so
super since we're talking about the
batman v superman superman we have to go
by the explanation provided to us by man
of steel
as we learn from hologram russell crowe
in the movie he's not innately powerful
it's earth that gives him all his
amazing abilities he'll be a god to them
in fact on krypton his home world
superman wouldn't have any powers at all
superman gains his powers on earth
through the planet's weakened gravity
and its stronger sun relative to krypton
earth's sun is younger and brighter than
krypton's walls
the cells have drunk in its radiation
earth's gravity is weaker
yet its atmosphere is more nourishing
now you're probably thinking that's
pretty silly there's no way the sun and
gravity can rationally explain a man's
ability to fly and lift up an airplane
but it kinda can
if krypton has a much heavier gravity
than earth an alien coming from
superman's home planet could lift
objects no human
could this is because a kryptonian's
muscles would have adapted to the
heavier gravity of krypton think of an
astronaut on the moon
the moon has a gravity roughly equal to
1 6 that of earth's
since the mass of an object is constant
if you weigh 200 pounds on earth and you
go to the moon you'll weigh
1 6th of that approximately 33 pounds
this is why astronauts can so easily
jump around on the moon's surface even
when carrying hundreds of pounds of
equipment and that brings us to my next
point the changing gravity
also affecting how much a person could
conceivably lift
a human who could lift a hundred pounds
on earth could then lift 600 pounds on
the moon but now instead of the earth
and the moon
we have krypton and the earth since the
earth's gravity is weaker than krypton
superman weighs far less here as such
he's able to leap tall buildings in a
single bound and lift seemingly
impossible objects
is it perfect flight admittedly no but
that's where the other half of his power
set comes in
the sun when it comes to the sun
superman draws his powers just like any
normal plant does
the light from the sun that reaches the
earth is composed mostly of non-ionizing
radiation
what's that mean well this radiation
doesn't carry enough energy to ionize
or steal electrons from atoms and
molecules
it has enough energy to excite atoms but
doesn't change their charge
think of non-ionizing radiation as an
easy listening rock station
it's like the eagles of radiation
compare that to ionizing radiation
the black sabbath of radiation carrying
enough hard rock energy to rip electrons
off of atoms and molecules
ionizing radiation is the reason you
wear lead vests when you get your x-rays
done
and it's the type of radiation that
everyone worries about when talking
about nuclear reactors
this stuff is the dangerous stuff anyway
knowing that we can now have more
insight into how superman's powers work
during photosynthesis plants soak up
non-ionizing rays the healthy ones and
convert them into chemical energy
this energy is then used to fuel the
plant's growth superman does the exact
same thing
storing up non-ionizing rays from the
sun and converting it into energy
normal humans get vitamin d in a tan
from the sun superman gets super speed
and laser vision the world is an
unfair place this also begs the question
why is superman's fortress of solitude
in the arctic
a part of the world that gets
significantly less light than like
99 of the globe not a great plan
superman may be strong but he's not
bright
if he was smarter the fortress of
solitude would be in like the bahamas or
something
and it would be called like the tiki hut
of solitude make it happen dc
in short without the earth's gravity and
sunlight superman just becomes
man man i guess what
we actually see it happen in man of
steel when superman boards general zod's
spaceship and is exposed to krypton's
atmosphere for the first time he
immediately falls to the floor and
starts spitting up blood
this means that by calculating the
gravitational force on krypton we can
now duplicate a force on earth that will
easily defeat
superman star henry cavill bulked up to
play superman and man of steel
by the actor's own account he weighed
203 pounds during filming
according to stack.com an elite athlete
in top physical condition
should be able to lift twice his own
body weight through a variety of
exercises so a normal henry cavill can
lift about 406 pounds on a good day
now let's look at the new movie in the
trailer for batman v superman we see
superman successfully
lift a rocket which weighs approximately
000 pounds or 75 000 kilos divide this
number by how much a normal henry cavill
can lift and we get how many times
stronger superman is to a normal human
funny enough when you do that it's
actually
406 times stronger weird 406
squared anyway this means that superman
is about 406 times
stronger than what a normal henry cavill
would be since the mass of an object
never changes this implies that for
superman to be 406 times stronger on
earth
krypton's gravity would also have to be
406 times stronger
earth's gravity is 9.8 meters per second
squared so multiplying that number by
406 gives us the gravity of krypton
3991 meters per second squared
that's insane our own sun
has a gravitational force of 274 meters
per second squared
thus in order to replicate krypton's
gravity you would need to create a force
14 times greater than that of the
sun no wonder superman is super it's
also no wonder zod's plan to terraform
earth fail
looks like some kind of gravity weapon
it's working in tandem with their ship
somehow they're increasing the earth's
mass clouding the atmosphere with
my god they're terraforming
what what are you thinking these
kryptonians man really strong but just
stupid stupid people fortress of
solitude in the arctic
terraforming earth to the gravitational
weight of krypton come on
come on guys ugh luckily in order to win
this fight batman doesn't have to do any
terraforming knowing that in the lore of
the movies superman is 406 times
stronger than a normal human to damage
the guy all batman needs to do is punch
him with 406 times the force of a normal
human punch and while that may
sound like a lot it's actually pretty
easy in fact we can punch superman with
a
thousand times the force of a normal
human punch
oh yeah in 2013 scientists at uc
berkeley created a robotic muscle
a thousand times stronger than a human
being these robot muscles which are made
from a material that's also in cameras
and missile guidance systems can throw
objects 50 times heavier over a distance
five
times its length within seconds using
these robotic muscles batman could
create a mechanical suit with a punch
nearly two and a half times
greater than superman's so much for
creating a fair
fight between these two superman is at a
disadvantage here
that scene from the trailer oh yeah
that's entirely plausible
superman should be scared but batman
doesn't stop
there he ain't gonna fight fair he's the
dark knight
bruce would figure out a way to tip the
balance in his favor
sure robotic armor a thousand times
greater than a human should be enough to
knock out the so-called man of steel
but batman doesn't want to take any
chances in this fight he would want to
weaken
superman and he could do that through
the other half of superman's power
source
the sun no batman isn't going to block
out the sun that'd be stupid but he can
use
ionizing radiation remember superman
drinks up
non-ionizing radiation like a plant to
fuel his powers
that's the safe stuff but on earth
ionizing radiation is pretty easy to
come by
x-rays nuclear power plants radon and as
we all know
it's dangerous exposure to ionizing
radiation results in mutation
radiation sickness cancer even death if
superman is exposed to ionizing rays
he's gonna absorb that harmful radiation
weakening him in the same way he absorbs
the sun's
non-ionizing rays for strength couple
that with a punch two and a half times
the strength of supes and you got
yourself a fight
don't believe me about this radiation
stuff well look no further than the
comic book batman v superman is based on
the dark knight returns in the comic
although it's not directly spelled out
superman is exposed to ionizing
radiation from a nuclear fallout
the result he immediately shrivels up
like a prune
in fact superman is so weakened by this
exposure that when he fights batman
later on he gets beat senseless that's
right
in the very comic batman v superman is
based on
batman the ultimate long shot actually
wins so in summary all you need to do to
beat superman is expose him to some
radiation
be it via x-rays radon uranium take your
pick and then pummel him to death with
some robotic muscles but hold on
i hear you say that's far from easy who
on earth could possibly have access to
all of that
well who else but bruce wayne bruce
wayne is a billionaire entrepreneur
he can do anything he wants how much
does crafting an
armor of super strong robot muscle cost
doesn't matter batman's a billionaire he
probably funded the research for it in
the first place and remember that's
billionaire with a b
he could make a hundred robot suits and
then buy a tropical island and then
build a temple
on that island worshiping george clooney
and his bat nipples
he's a billionaire he can do whatever
crazy things he imagines just by signing
a check as for getting his hands on
radioactive substances
bruce wayne already owns dozens of
nuclear power plants
wayne enterprises per batman lore has
multiple divisions which include wayne
construction
wayne biotech wayne steele wayne weapons
and wayne industries all bruce wayne has
to do is borrow some uranium from his
local power plant or radon or whatever
or better yet just stage the battle at
his own power plant
once lured in superman won't know what
hit him but we will
ionizing radiation followed up with
robotic muscles a thousand times
stronger than that of a human and that
loyal theorists is the true irony here
the one thing that'll defeat superman
the all-american hero
is the most american thing of all
capitalism
the green substance superman should be
worried about ain't kryptonite
it's the almighty dollar but hey
that's just a theory a film theory
and cut want to see more theories about
all your favorite superheroes
punch that subscribe button with the
force of a thousand sons
and while you're at it if you're craving
more superhero action check out
wisecrack and their new video exploring
the hidden meaning
in pixar's the incredibles you know for
as much as i liked this movie i always
got a weird vibe from it and it looks
like they did too
the greatest people in the world are
only great through their blood
hard work does not make you great is
that really what the movie is trying to
tell us well my friends over at the
wisecrack channel are looking to see
whether there's actually any validity to
that claim
the guys over there have a bunch of
smart funny videos that aim to open your
mind about your favorite movies video
games tv shows books
anyway you slice it if you like this
channel chances are you're gonna like
theirs so i recommend going on over and
showing them some love and speaking of
disney movies with questionable themes
zootopia oh yeah we're covering that one
next time